[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
par exemple
médico je suis médecin je pense que ce
qu'on fait on peut le varier à l'infini
on peut faire des tas de choses
différentes dans une vie mais ce qu'on
est c'est ce qu'on a acquis entre
peut-être je sais pas 18 25 ans
c'est le moment de la formation
peut-être de la déformation où on a
acquis quelque chose qui est de l'ordre
de la vision du monde de la manière dont
on va se projeter dans le monde alors on
peut être formé pour être un journaliste
pour être un juriste pour être un
policier un magistrat ou un médecin
voilà ce sont chaque fois des visions du
monde et cette vision du monde on l'a
décline de façon différente et ce que je
voudrais partager avec vous c'est que
justement la médecine est sans doute une
des visions du monde une des manières de
regarder le monde la plus féconde c'est
un passeport pour le monde parce que
c'est un métier qui vous fait vos projet
dans l'existence des autres dans tout ce
que les autres sont et que vous n'êtes
pas et que vous devez comprendre
aujourd'hui quand on parle de la
médecine on a tendance à penser la
technique on pense aux hôpitaux scanner
machine très compliqué au traitement
compliqué c'est ça existe bien sûr mais
la médecine c'est pas ça moi j'ai choisi
ce métier en référence à un grand-père
mon grand-père qui m'avait élevé une
partie de mon enfant qui était un vieux
médecin c'est un médecin je dirais même
pas du 20e siècle du 19e et les médecins
du 19e ils n'étaient pas très différents
des médecins de Molière ou même de
Rabelais c'est-à-dire que c'était des
gens qui au fond n'avaient pas beaucoup
de moyens d'agir vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de techniques vous avez pas
beaucoup d'examens complémentaires la
radiologie ils avaient pas les
antibiotiques vous avez pas tout ça
et pourtant ils étaient médecins
et qu'est-ce que ça voulait dire alors
d'être médecin sans pouvoir guérir et
bien c'est une façon de regarder les
autres et de regarder la vie des autres
et d'essayer de la comprendre d'une
façon qui ne soit pas une manière
magique vous savez pendant longtemps la
maladie c'était la malédiction quelqu'un
qui se tordait de douleur il était
maudit il était possédé et puis il y a
des médecins grecs qui ont pensé
que non c'était pas ça c'était le
fonctionnement normal du corps
était compréhensible et que son
fonctionnement anormal pathologique
pouvait être compris aussi même s'il
n'était pas encore capable de le
comprendre il y avait cette idée vous
savez quand il parlait du diabète
qu'est-ce que c'était le diabète c'était
quelqu'un qui buvait beaucoup et qui
pissait beaucoup qui mangeait beaucoup
et qui maigrissait tout passer à travers
lui diabète c'est à dire on ne savait
pas ce que c'était on n'avait pas encore
évidemment la notion du la base de
l'insuline et tout ça mais il y avait
cette idée que ça n'était pas une
possession que c'était quelque chose
qu'on pouvait regarder et comprendre et
ça mon grand-père était vraiment
tout à fait caractéristique de ça c'est
un homme pour lequel la médecine était
un art plus qu'une science et c'était un
engagement et c'était aussi une
discipline littéraire c'est à dire
c'était des gens qui avaient à cette
époque là a pris le grec le latin
d'ailleurs Rabelais il était devenu
médecin comme ça parce qu'il était un
très bon les trait et que pouvant lire
Vésale Galien etc ils doivent des
médecins voilà alors ça c'était
ce que je pensais trouver moi en faisant
en faisant la médecine je pensais
trouver l'engagement mon grand-père il
avait fait deux guerres assez dures la
première en coupant des bras et des
jambes au front et la deuxième
dans un camp de concentration parce
qu'il faisait partie d'un réseau de
résistance donc
il y avait cette dimension d'engagement
il y avait ces dimensions littéraires il
y avait des sept dimension humaine bon
c'est vrai que quand je suis arrivé moi
dans ce métier les choses avaient un peu
changé on était devenu
une médecine scientifique bon je suis
content quand je suis malade je préfère
voir un scientifique un poète à vrai
dire mais c'était pas ce que je voulais
voilà et donc
je suis allé le chercher ailleurs et
c'est souvent le hasard qui vous emmène
comme ça moi c'est le service militaire
et sauvé quand ça existait été souvent
un moment comme ça de croisement bizarre
on disait que Joseph Kessel quand il
s'était engagé comme ça il avait marqué
sa profession il a mis journaliste et
l'adjudant qui l'a reçu a lu journalier
ce qui fait qu'il a cassé des cailloux
pendant 6 mois avant qu'il comprenne que
c'est voilà bref moi je n'étais pas tout
à fait aussi grave mais j'étais
neurologue on m'a mis dans une maternité
j'ai fait mon service militaire dans une
maternité parce que c'est comme ça je
fais des accouchements moi pendant tout
le monde ça se mettait en Tunisie
et au fond ça a été une occasion
puisqu'on parle d'existence de faire
pivoter la manière de voir au fond le
monde là encore parce que moi j'étais un
petit étudiant en médecine qui avait
bien travaillé qui pensait que la
maladie était
différente et qu'il fallait mon métier
c'était les différencier ces maladies
que finalement l'être humain c'est
elle-même partout et puis en Tunisie je
me suis rendu compte c'était un peu le
contraire ce qu'au fond la maladie et la
même partout en gros évidemment il y a
des variations mais et que ce qui change
c'est l'être humain que vous avez devant
vous c'est ça c'est sa culture c'est sa
psychologie c'est sa vie c'est c'est
toute ça toute sa richesse en tant
qu'être humain en tant que personne que
vous avez devant vous c'est ça qui est
le finalement qui a derrière la maladie
et c'est ça qui s'est mis à me
passionner alors je trouve que j'ai eu
la chance à ce moment-là de rencontrer
cette ce mouvement
le Médecin sans Frontières qui qui
commença à apparaître quand je suis
revenu de Tunisie c'était le tout début
c'était le tout début de ces de ces ONG
vous savez que la France a été un peu on
aime bien dire qu'on est le pays des
droits de l'homme toi c'est vrai
Voltaire Diderot Rousseau etc mais ce
qu'on oublie de dire c'est que juste
après ces philosophes du 18e siècle il y
a eu les révolutions il y a eu la guerre
en France
et que finalement notre pays a été
plutôt receveur de l'aide humanitaire de
l'aide internationale c'est nous qui
avions finalement les guerres chez nous
c'est nous qui avions les les désastres
donc l'outil humanitaire il s'est
développé aux Etats-Unis s'est développé
en Suisse et développer en Scandinavie
mais au fond chez nous il a été assez
assez en retard et c'est dans les années
70 fin des années 70
quand la France était suffisamment
prospère les trentes glorieuses quand on
avait terminé ces Guer garde Algérie
gardien d'Indochine etc que on a été en
mesure finalement de se tourner vers les
autres et d'inventer un nouvel outil ce
nouvel outil c'était ces ONG Médecin
sans Frontières en tête qui est apparue
en 1971 à l'occasion de la guerre du
bienfa et que j'ai rejoint un peu plus
tard
et là ça a été pour moi une sorte de de
choc parce que bon moi j'étais interne
hôpitaux de Paris j'ai passé l'internat
j'ai été
formé à faire une médecine très
technique et tout d'un coup je me suis
retrouvé propulsé avec les autres avec
mes camarades et compagnons dans ces
comme dans ces combats si vous voulez on
s'est retrouvé un Afghanistan se
retrouver
Nicaragua on s'est retrouvé en Angola en
Mozambique
au Sri Lanka au Salvador enfin dans le
monde entier
et c'est là que nous avons compris que
finalement la médecine était ce
passeport pour le monde dont je parle
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que il y avait là quelque
chose d'absolument extraordinaire qui
était cette possibilité que nous avions
individuellement parce que n'agissions
pas pour un état nous agissions pas
officiellement je demande aux agissions
à titre privé et dans un monde qui était
bloqué par la guerre froide avec vous
savez ces risques nucléaires de partout
mais nous pouvions entraîner nous
pouvions pénétrer sans frontières
jusqu'aux autres et donc l'existence des
autres qu'on avait l'habitude de scruter
dans nos cabinets de médecins ou dans
nos constellations dans nos hôpitaux et
bien là c'est existence c'était
l'existence du monde qui était devant
nous c'est-à-dire c'était une existence
qui était démultipliée par ces terrains
et différences et guerres que nous
connaissions pas ces pays ces cultures
différentes voilà alors moi je me suis
passionné pour ça et j'ai complété ma
formation pour essayer de comprendre un
peu quelque chose donc je vais aller
m'inscrire à Sciences Po à Paris
en demandant une sorte d'équivalence si
vous voulez alors ils prennent ils
aiment bien toujours prendre un pompier
un séminariste enfin bref voilà moi ils
m'ont pris dans l'eau quoi et bon j'ai
fait ces études pour essayer de
devoir un peu où on mettait les pieds de
comprendre c'est culture de comprendre
tout ça
avec une idée quand même qui était
celle que j'ai mentionné au début c'est
à dire qu'il y avait dans la médecine
pour moi cette dimension de littérature
cette dimension de partage il suffit pas
de vivre les choses encore faut-il les
partager il faut être capable de les
exprimer il faut être capable de les de
les faire comprendre aux autres de les
faire percevoir aux autres voilà et
j'avais certainement cette envie et
c'est pour ça que après avoir fait ses
études complémentaires
je me suis risqué à essayer d'écrire un
petit peu mais d'écrire des choses
techniques des choses qui étaient au
plus près de mon expérience bon et
j'ai écrit mon des essais sur l'action
humanitaire et les relations
internationales des choses comme ça
et puis je moi-même après je me suis mis
à faire des conférences à Sciences Po
j'avais un séminaire là-bas alors les
étudiants c'est comme ils sont gentils
étudiants que leurs profs ils veulent
faire plaisir alors ils prennent le
bouquin du du prof en l'occurrence le
mien il le désosse complètement ils font
un exposé dessus voilà et vous vous êtes
désespéré parce que vous dites mais
c'est pas ça que je voulais dire c'est
pas au fond le ce squelette là qui me
raconte au fond c'est pas l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est pas ça c'est pour ça
que je veux transmettre ce que je
voudrais transmettre c'est des portraits
c'est des paysages c'est des émotions
c'est des choses senties et dans des
essais un peu techniques un peu sec ça
passe pas
au fond il y a que la littérature qui
permet de ça la littérature qui
permettent alors sauf si on est peintre
ou si on a d'autres formes de
d'art à sa disposition mais moi j'en
avais pas c'est ma forme d'art c'est
l'écrit donc la littérature mais la
littérature c'est un morceau
un surmontable
pour un médecin c'est difficile parce
que pendant que les autres qui faisaient
des études littéraires lisez la
recherche du temps perdu vous vous
appreniez l'école latérale de l'artère
les entériques supérieures etc donc on a
des lacunes énormes et puis il y a pas
que ça il y a aussi le serment
d'Hippocrate vous savez qu'à la fin de
vos études quand vous êtes terminé vos
études avant de devenir docteur donc
avant de passer votre test vous prêtez
ce serment alors c'est rien du tout il
fait beau cet après-midi on met un texte
sur le mur vous signez ça au même toche
sur le dos signer le truc vous prêtez le
serment bon ben voilà puis après
après ce serment revient en vous c'est
très étonnant et qu'est-ce qui dit ce
serment il vous dit vous pourrez dans
votre pratique tout voir tout savoir
vous entrerez partout les patients vous
montreront tout leur maison leur cœur
leur corps leur maladie leur souffrance
tout à une condition c'est que vous ne
raconterez jamais ce que vous avez vu
alors imaginez-vous quand vous allez
vous disposer à écrire des romans
forcément vous allez puiser dans vos
souvenirs vous allez évoquer des gens
que vous avez croisé que vous avez
rencontrés et donc vous êtes tétanisé
par cette idée de violer le serment
d'Hippocrate et d'éventuellement
pouvoir blesser quelqu'un et d'une
certaine manière vous parjurer alors il
faut faire un détour et moi ce détour je
les fais par le temps c'est-à-dire par
le roman historique premier roman que
j'ai écrit il passait au 17e siècle fin
du 17e siècle mais il retrace une
histoire vraie que l'histoire du premier
ambassadeur qui a été envoyé par Louis
XIV en Éthiopie et il se trouve que ce
chemin moi je l'avais fait
depuis les déserts du de cartoon et de
et du Soudan quand on arrive au pied de
ces montagnes Ethiopiennes de ces hauts
plateaux éthiopien et comme montre
là-haut et à l'époque c'était pour
rencontrer le Négus donc d'une certaine
manière il y avait une vibration entre
ce que j'avais vécu je pouvais mettre ma
vie dedans et en même temps la distance
du temps qui me permettait de ne pas
compromettre quiconque donc j'ai
commencé comme ça un petit livre puis je
les ai envoyé par la poste on a refusé
un peu on a refusé deux à l'usure vous
savez comment ça se passe normalement
ils finissent par craquer alors voilà et
finalement j'ai eu la chance aussi
d'avoir des prix et on a mentionné tout
à l'heure le prix Goncourt c'est souvent
critiqué les prix en France on dit oui
c'est des jurés c'est tout ça c'est
magouillé etc ben moi j'avais pas
vraiment de comptage j'avais pas
vraiment de soutien et pourtant je dois
reconnaître que c'est grâce à ses prix
que que ma vie a changé et que j'ai pu
faire ce métier et depuis 25 ans c'est
vrai que j'explore à travers l'écrit à
travers le roman ce qui me passionne
c'est à dire la rencontre des autres les
autres existences qu'elles soient
d'autres cultures par exemple dans rouge
Brésil c'était la rencontre entre les
Européens et ce Brésil
des Indiens de la baie de Rio qui
réservait effectivement des des
surprises énormes et qui sont à
l'origine finalement de la du concept du
bon sauvage
ça peut être des l'existence dans une
seule personne de culture différente qui
tendent un personnage et qui le font en
quelque sorte basculer balancer entre
entre deux cultures c'est ça qui me
passionne moi c'est ça que je raconte
dans mes romans voilà
et simplement pour continuer d'écrire il
faut continuer à vivre parce que si vous
voulez mettre de la vie dans vos écrits
si vous voulez que vos écrits soient non
pas
mort mais vivant il faut que ils
viennent de vous quoi et c'est un piège
ça c'est-à-dire que quand j'ai commencé
à pouvoir vivre de mes ma plume si vous
voulez c'était vraiment un piège c'est à
dire l'idée de semaine dans sa tour
d'ivoire d'écrire etc et au bout d'un
moment on n'a plus rien à dire c'est
pour ça que à chaque fois qu'on m'a
proposé des choses qui étaient parfois
dangereuses ou difficiles je les ai
acceptés et c'est comme ça que je me
suis retrouvé notamment ben ça a l'air
de France au Sénégal qui m'a été
proposée
dans des conditions c'est un très gros
poste très difficile mais
c'était pour moi
une sorte de défi d'abord de savoir si
j'en ai des capables et puis
de savoir que grâce à ça j'allais
pouvoir faire entrer de nouveaux thèmes
de nouvelles images de nouveaux
personnages dans ma création romanesque
voilà alors je voudrais conclure par
trois petits mots
trois petits mots simples par rapport à
tout ça l'humanitaire je l'ai évoqué
il a été très à la mode il les moins
il y a beaucoup d'argent dans
l'humanitaire et beaucoup de moyens
internationaux etc un espace humanitaire
qui se réduit parce que de plus en plus
dangereux d'aller dans les pays en
conflit mais surtout il y a la montée de
nouvelle préoccupations notamment
l'écologie etc qui aujourd'hui sont plus
visibles j'aimerais que les deux se
combinent et
j'aimerais que l'écologie ne se
transforme pas un jour en une écologie
anti-humaine si vous laissez vrai que
l'humanité est responsable de beaucoup
de dommages à la planète mais elle n'est
pas pour autant coupable et il faut
essayer de restaurer une sorte de
d'équilibre entre notre sollicitude pour
la planète et celle que nous devons
conserver pour l'humanité
la deuxième chose c'est l'écriture
je pense qu'il faut
savoir que ça n'est pas réservé à une
caste notamment le roman c'est quelque
chose que chacun peut à quoi chacun peut
s'essayer en tout cas mais à condition à
10 mètres de la vie et l'écriture c'est
vraiment comme George emprun avait écrit
un jour l'écriture c'est vraiment la vie
c'est-à-dire que c'est la vie comme
production mais c'est la vie aussi comme
source et dernier mot par rapport à cet
index notamment je voudrais dire à ceux
qui choisissent leur vocation
aujourd'hui leur voix
ce que j'ai voulu essayer de montrer
avec ce cas personnel un peu particulier
comme le sont tous les cas personnels
c'est qu'au fond quand on choisit sa
voie à 18 ans on est souvent tétanisé en
se disant je vais choisir quelque chose
qui va m'engager pour la vie c'est vrai
c'est vrai que vous serez ce que vous
allez choisir mais en même temps vous
pourrez faire tellement de choses à
partir de là
que finalement
cette liberté reste très grande et que
vous avez la vie devant vous merci